I'm delighted to say we can speak to the
General Secretary of the Royal College
of Nursing Pat Cullen now thanks so much
for for joining me it's a clearly
escalating the strikes in quite a big
way tell us why
well first of all with a very heavy
heart this escalation was announced
today
um and it's simply because
we can find no resolution with this
government to the strike on behalf of
every every nurse that I I represent
you mentioned uh in your statement
towards the end of it that this action
that you you're taking uh already taken
and will be now taking more of must not
be in vain are you concerned that
there's a chance it might be
no I'll never give up hope that the
government will come to the table and
start to find ways to talk to us to
resolve um this strike on behalf of
every single nurse that has taken part
and Strikes so far and indeed and more
importantly on behalf of our patients so
I can't give up hope for what I'm saying
to the Prime Minister today is please
choose choose talking over strike action
on saving the NHS is really really
important to every single nurse that
I've written to today to announce the
next 48 hours to and what if he said
back to you what you just said choose
talking rather than strike action
sorry could you repeat that to me please
what what would be your response if the
government said to you exactly what you
just uh proposed saying to him choose
talking over strike action
I would be absolutely delighted I would
settle in which table do I need to be at
right now and I will be at it doesn't
matter what time of the day or night I
will be there to represent the hundred
thousand plus nurses
um in England that will have to take
part in this strike action at the
beginning of March if this government
continues to not get into a room and
start to negotiate so there will be no
and we will not be found wanting within
the Royal College of Nursing to try and
bring an end to the strike we'll do that
on behalf of every single nurse and
every patient and that that deserves
better in this country and do you have a
sympathy is not the right word but do
you have um any sort of vague
or use sympathy but it's not quite the
word I'm looking for for the government
in terms of the challenge they have at
the moment with so many different
sectors striking some with more
legitimate grounds than others a debate
for others to have that if they agree to
a percentage price rise for for one
sector however deserving they might be
that it sets a precedent for other
sectors
look those are tough decisions that the
Prime Minister must take that's a very
tough decisions that people that hold
High elective office must take all of
the time but I'll tell you who I have
serious sympathy for it's every single
member of nursing staff that are coming
on shift at seven o'clock in the morning
and at eight o'clock in the evening
knowing that half of their Workforce
isn't going to be available to look
after their passions and that they're
doing their very very best to reduce the
risk and that our patients are facing
every single day because we're 47 000
vacant posts in England have sympathy on
all of those nurses that when they want
to go off shift and start to go home
that they're faced with the position
where they can and are struggling with
paying their utility bills so my
sympathy lies with them but also my
thanks lies with them as well because
without those nurses continuing to work
in the crisis that they're working in
and what still at would our Health
Service be in and they are continuing to
look after their patients Against All
Odds every single minute of the day and
night in terms of your point of every
single minute of the day and night
clearly there's a difference in this set
of strikes to come on the first of March
that it will be for 48 hours solid not
just 12 hours during the day you you say
in your statement I'll do whatever it
takes to ensure patient safety is
protected presumably that is harder to
do in this round of strikes than the
previous ones given the 48-hour nature
and given that intensive care and other
areas are included for the first time
of course it is
I that this will serious pressure on the
NHS even more pressure than it's under
at the minute but it put pressure in
those nursing staff that are continuing
to try and provide services but what I
will say to every patient that's
listening our nursing staff will not
create any further risk that you are
continuing to face every single day but
why what and there is a big pot there
will be pressure find as there has been
during the first six days of strike that
have happened to date during the first
three months but this will involve
nursing staff that have not taken strike
in the first three months and they will
be involved in this strike but again my
play is back to the Prime Minister
please step in please try and get around
the table and talk to me and let's save
the NHS from the crisis that it's in so
given that it will be harder will
patient safety be at risk
there is no doubt and every single
member of nursing staff's mind the risk
that patients face every single day how
can they not be facing risk sitting on
wearing less 7 million plus people
sitting on wedding list year on year
there's serious risk associated with
that the risk that's associated with 47
000 nursing staff missing in England
every day when there should those posts
should be filled how are we going to get
those posts filled how are we going to
make sure that we can keep our nursing
staff in the Health Service and recruit
more nursing staff and by paying them a
decent wage resolving the pay dispute
that they've got for this year and then
look at what we're going to do in the
years to come but this is for the prime
minister to resolve and resolve as a
matter of urgency and on the pay part of
it and I know it's about much more than
that but it's perhaps the most tangible
thing that we can discuss discuss here I
think you originally asked them please
call correct me if I'm wrong for 18 or
19 and the government offered four or
five and at some point in the last few
months you said on Sky News that you'd
be willing to meet halfway is is that
still the sort of position somewhere
between five and and 18 percent
I have never put a figure on it actually
I've said let's meet halfway I've also
said that we won't negotiate in public
we actually
um owed to every member of nursing staff
to get around a table and have those
talks together at that table I will lay
out the plans I've got for our nursing
staff that will bring an end to these
strikes and ensure that our nursing
staff can get back inside their
hospitals care for their patients where
they want to be not standing on packet
lines losing another day's pay and the
Prime Minister can set out his plans and
let's come to an agreement that's what
nurses do that's what talks achieve so
let's start talking
if inflation Falls because it is likely
to do that in the months ahead based on
on various economic forecasts and
comparisons to last year would your
demands come down as well if inflation
comes down
look I've said time and time again and
we will meet the
veterinter table and we'll start talking
we'll take into consideration everything
that the Prime Minister wishes to put on
the table and we will discuss that we'll
put it to our nursing staff we'll have
those discussions and we're sure
together we can find a resolution to
this but resolutions can only be found
in a room when we start to talk and I am
ready and willing to talk to the Prime
Minister day or night I can't make that
any clearer Pat we uh we definitely hear
you land clear on that and we really
appreciate you joining us tonight and
answering all of our questions Pat
Cullen